wie kam ihnen dieses duell vw zwei
gorillas oder wie zwei menschen die us
präsident werden wollen doch wie zwei
gorillas
ich fand auch ganz aktuell oder
zumindest strecken das aktuelle
geschehen
wir wollen also zwei gestandene männer
präsidenten werden aber schaffen es
nicht eine zivilisierte debatte zu
führen also die amerikaner die zion
allem ein bisschen leid im moment bin
ich ein großer fan von amerika oder aber
ja ich persönlich habe ich auch nachdem
ich das gesehen habe ich heute so weit
für unwählbar
aber vielleicht sollten wir ja auch mal
überlegen oder wir müssen uns vielleicht
mal fragen warum sind denn die
amerikaner überhaupt an diesen punkt
angelangt
also vor allem weil er ist ja ein
symptom für etwas oder
also warum hat man ihn denn überhaupt
und jetzt hat man so viele probleme mit
ihm warum haben so viele menschen denn
damals überhaupt gewählt oder diesen
rüpel und jetzt am schluss stehen dann
diese beiden übrig also was ist da
schief gelaufen in dem land ich finde
diese frage eigentlich noch ziemlich
interessant oder vielleicht ist er auch
eine art phänomen das man ernst nehmen
muss sondern was ist in amerika da
passiert was man am schluss einfach
trapp gewählt hat oder dass man ihm
zutraut okay er hilft uns jetzt aber er
steht uns bei gegen das politische
establishment oder vielleicht auch gegen
die medien aber finde das muss man halt
schon ein bisschen genauer anschauen
oder jetzt nicht nur sich so auf die
partie konzentrieren und vielleicht hat
er da eine erklärung dafür